street fighter 5 doesn't drop till next  week but we already know who's joining  the roster is dlc alex who first  appeared in Street Fighter 3 will arrive  sometime in March we already knew he was  coming but thanks to a tweet from the  developers now we know when Alex was  announced alongside Balrog guile ibuki  jury and urien back in December but we  didn't know who would show up first he  can be unlocked in game but you can also  spend real-world money to unlock him  right away if you're so inclined the  final price hasn't been revealed another  tweet confirmed that ps3 controllers  will work with the ps4 version of Street  Fighter 5 so you'll have plenty of  characters to choose from and multiple  controllers to use there's a free story  mode hitting the game this summer too  that's plenty of content but if capcom  announces anymore you'll hear about it  from GameSpot  Oh